these red velvet cinnamon roll pancakes
are a delightful and fun way to
celebrate Valentine's Day with your
loved ones this year I could go on and
on about just how good these are but to
be honest my words will never do them
Justice yep these are it I just want you
to imagine a stack of soft tender and
fluffy red velvet pancakes that are
laced with caramelized cinnamon sugar
Swirls and topped with a lush cream
cheese glaze it's no secret that
cinnamon roll pancakes have been a fan
favorite and I think that this is my
favorite version by far I mean imagine
waking up to a stack of these as a kid
on Valentine's Day I think they would
capture my heart part two start off by
making a super simple and decadent red
velvet pancake batter that will make
these extra soft and fluffy then mix
together your cinnamon sugar swirl then
preheat a large scalet over medium heat
and grease with butter and to make these
extra fun I decided to use a heart mold
but they can totally be made without one
and if you're using a mold the key here
is to get the mold really hot and spray
with non-stick cooking spray before
adding the pancake batter cook low and
slow and then mix together the
ingredients for that dreamy cream cheese
glaze then play and enjoy